hey good to be here how you doing mel
uh
doing a lot of drinking here you know
people always talk about how honest you
are when you're drunk i feel like i'm
way more honest when i'm hungover you
know when i'm drunk i can lie all day
cops like you've been drinking i'm like
no way
when i'm hungover that's when i'm honest
my life's in shambles i have nothing to
live for you know your friend's like you
want to get brunch you're like
i've never liked you
everything's a lie when you're drunk you
know you're like hey it's the best night
ever these are my good friends and she's
super hot then you wake up like as a
waste of time i spent too much money and
that's a dude
i blacked out last week that's
embarrassing yeah i told my roommate
he's like oh you blacked out oh that
means you forgot to brush your teeth
last night i was like wow that is the
least of my worries yeah
i'm more concerned with the lipstick i'm
wearing why i sent my mom a dick pic
i don't know drink a lot of single guy
it's scary to hit on girls you gotta
drink for that you know
it's hard to hit on girls i feel like
women [ __ ] on men more hit on us ladies
when's that feminist movie going to kick
in you know
you can say whatever you want to a guy i
had an older lady approached me once she
goes ooh i'm going to kidnap you i was
like wow i could never say that to a
woman
i said that to a lady she calls the
police i would be curious to know what a
woman could say that would offend me
like all right i'm going to take you
home drug you take advantage of you and
film it i'd be like all right well at
least let me pay for the uber
[Music]
this is how sexy girls are i was out to
dinner once this girl leans over during
the meal and goes hey i'm not wearing
any underwear i was like oh my god
that's hot then i realized why is that
sexy
has underwear ever been a huge obstacle
for a guy
has any guy ever taken a girl's jeans
off seeing panties have been like it's
gonna be a long night
put a pot of coffee on i can't crack
that coat
well that's how hot you are gals you can
tell my article of clothing you're not
wearing i can't even see it missing i'm
already turned on
doesn't work for me as a guy i can't
pull that off i lean over during dinner
hey i'm not wearing the underwear she's
going to go uh-oh
what happened
laundry day diarrhea need a wet wipe
talk to me
i don't know it's just tough to date now
you know we have no patience anymore we
want everything immediately now we're
getting quick we want uber tinder
netflix everything's so quick now the
only thing we don't want quickest sex
what is that going to catch
up i was with a girl the other night i
finished kind of early she's like hey
what's going on here i was like well
these are the times we're living in
come on
i don't have the patience for vagina to
be buffering let's go
you're an analog girl in the digital
world sister pick it up
i don't know maybe i'm screwed up
sexually you know i caught my parents
having sex when i was 8 21 and today
and uh the idea of your parents having
sex is so horrifying isn't it that's why
i'm surprised parents don't use that as
a threat
right wouldn't that be so effective like
hey timmy you better clean that room and
your mom are gonna go at it
all right
i know that math does billy i got a d
i'll show you some d all right i'll
study
i'm sorry i'll study
oh yeah
just found out my ex-girlfriend's
getting breast implants that blew my
mind i use the term breast implants i
don't like the term fake breasts doesn't
make sense to me because the breasts are
real it's just the [ __ ] inside that's
fake the breasts are still real it's
kind of like the bible the book is real
it's just the [ __ ] inside that's fake
[Applause]
yeah boy the bible's a real buzzkill huh
what a bummer they don't like anything
fun in the bible they hate gays they
hate trans that's gonna be great when
doing stuff so sexually advanced not
even in the bible you know like i love
[ __ ] my vacuum cleaner the guy's like
all right you're good
maybe i'll try it
yeah
and i don't know some people are
probably offended some people get so mad
when you make fun of their religion
which i never got if you believe it just
believe it what does it matter what i
say like i believe in gravity if
somebody's like hey gravity's not real
i'd be like all right good luck out
there
i wouldn't be mad i'm just like hey stay
off the roof buddy yeah all right
i will say this about uh dating i'm sick
of good-looking people
there's none here so we're good but you
know
beautiful people i'm done with you you
know like i can't relate you don't know
what it's like out there like i went on
date with this girl recently she was so
pretty this girl was gorgeous beautiful
beautiful woman way out of my league but
she had nothing to say she was boring so
i kind of checked out and she goes look
i can tell you don't like me just want
to sleep with me
and i was like well yeah but that's your
fault
and she was like [ __ ] you a board's a
pretty face i'm like but that's all you
worked on hours on your hair makeup
outfit get a [ __ ] knock knock joke
together
i don't get these good looking people
they spend 100 of their time on their
looks zero on their personality you just
assume that part's amazing why would you
work on that too give it 80 20. 80 20.
go to the gym all day put makeup on and
watch half a documentary half yeah
i know i'm not a hot guy you know before
i did i'm writing jokes in my hand
limerick's anecdotes i'm bringing it
baby i'm tap dancing out there you know
like if a girl told me mark you're funny
but you're not that hot i'd be like i
know that's why i'm funny
all right thanks a lot thank you